should anything go wrong at this stage
the only thing that will go bang is a
small detonator
still enough to take your hand off but
not enough
to completely kill you
[Music]
i was actually an ex-training nco at the
demolition school
and i was blue lighted from my base
into the centre of london because they
were having a few issues with the the
new equipment the abrasive cutter
we had arrived to a cordon come through
and then nothing
the whole place is deserted obviously
because
right in the center of this evacuation
is the item that's concerning us
many air drop weapons in the war were
dropped and
failed to initiate uh 15
of everything that was dropped and still
current today fails to function
it's just by design those that don't
could be ticking
and it could have a clockwork fuse
inside and go and be ticking and maybe
it's
stuck so for fuse immunization
the bomb disposal officer will drill
into the fuse pump saline solution
into the fuse and it clogs it up so if
the bomb had
any chance of doing its final tick
it won't do it because we've now done
fuse immunization
but now the inside is full of explosives
so we somehow have to remove it so it's
very crude we cut into it
remove the metal casing and then place a
steamer
a high pressure steamer and it melts the
explosive
and it pours out underneath and then the
moment we are
at a level of explosive that is
considered safe either to move
or to destroy that is what we do and in
this case we
we put a charge on top of the
bomb and exploded it in the middle of
london
the uk jobs uh are relatively
safe i say relatively because you're
using conventional munition disposal
so something that has been manufactured
on purpose
to be fired dropped thrown whatever it
might be
when i move across to um
humanity and inclusion and started doing
humanitarian work
then you're in a different category
we're now having people
in their back yards making things or
being forced to make things
uh in an improvised manner so
it's not designed to function the same
way as a conventional munition
you don't know how it was built you
don't know the standards it was built to
you don't know the materials it was used
therefore the threat is much higher
when you approach an item like this
so um our task was to clear the urban
areas
we wanted to restore the buildings back
to normality so they could move back in
after being pushed out by dash
and i was doing various buildings and a
small
child came up to us and started pulling
on my shirt towers
in the cp which is the control point mr
mister
uh i found a rocket because the words
through my translator she said she's
found a rocket
i listen to children because they've got
nothing else to do but play
and they're the nosy ones as much as we
can educate them
um they're nosy so i listen to the child
and she took me to a building which was
not on my radar
at this time and uh
took me to the front entrance where i
stopped everybody and
had a quick assessment i said right we
need to move back
pulled everyone back
i ensure the safety is in place before i
do anything i'll make sure my medic's
there
everyone's brief they know exactly what
i'm going to do what my intentions will
be
because clearly i have a plan but
something could go wrong
i mark my way from where i start with
pickets left and right so if there's an
incident they'll follow where my pickets
were
all my markings or my spray paint
whatever it is i use on the ground
and i listen to this child's description
she said rock it
but everything to them is either a mine
or a rocket
and i'm having to do fingertips i'm
having to use my
my tools my paintbrush the building has
reinforcing inside so my
metal detector becomes a little bit
irrelevant
so it's down to fingertip search i'm
creeping forward
my fingers are moving rubbish i'm
assessing that rubbish before i move it
but the best tool is my vision my eyes
if i can see it first then i can see the
threat
so i'm progressing in and it's dark
we're obviously inside a building
and my torch picks up a glint and i see
the first bead
of a crush wire it was actually a 24
bead crush wire and that's basically a
miniature pressure plate
any weight applied to the crush crush
wire
it would initiate and function the
detonator
but these things have been there for a
number of years now and
the dust builds up on it the rubbish the
wind has blown rubbish all over it
very difficult to find the child found
they saw uh what they thought was a
rocket they didn't find the switch
in fact in this case they were very
lucky they had entered
maybe a couple of steps into the
building and they'd seen
uh the projectile they haven't seen the
switch
the switch is the crush wire so if i
step on any part of this crush wire it
will initiate
so i now need to find i need to avoid
the switch and find
where does it go safely so i'm having to
trace
around the switch slowly it doesn't
matter how long this takes you do it
take as much time as you need and i find
that the switch leads to
a detonator and it was designed to catch
anyone wandering through this doorway
they'd simply step on the crush wire and
it would initiate
my job is to find this and
if possible do a separation of the
detonator
and the main charge what i call the big
bang little bang
scenario if the main charge is separated
from the detonator
then should anything go wrong at this
stage the only thing that will go bang
is a small detonator
still enough to take your hand off but
not enough
to completely kill you so i trace the
crush wire avoiding the switch keeping
away from the crush wire
make my way to the detonator so i peel
gently back the tape
which was holding the detonator to a
short piece of
deck cord which runs inside the main
projectile
so i will separate that and then i have
to create
physical separation i don't want that
destinator anywhere near the deck cord
once i have that separation i'm
virtually there
however then i want to assess the
battery
to ensure there's no other secondary
detonators no other main charges and
what i'm dealing with
is right in front of me and nothing else
attached to it and then i will
separate the destinating leads i'll take
a look a snip
cut the wire and then remove the
detonator for debt safety later on
once you've then did the bomb safe
is there just a feeling of relief
for a short time there's relief for the
individual item that you're dealing with
but then the complex that i'm in the
building complex has a series of
mouse holes so the little rat runs
between the buildings for the dash
and every single rat hunt rather i knew
having just dealt with this one
item i could have an item potentially
at every stage and every mousehole as
i'm going through this building
and i know what's i know the task in
front of me is long
and i have to come out for a break i
even found myself
asking myself what what the hell am i
doing here
i stopped and thought for one moment
what am i doing here
take a breath okay i know what i'm doing
i need to get on with it and
then you try and restore the area and
the building in this case to normality
when you're dealing with conventional
munition disposal in uk mainland
falklands or afghanistan i didn't feel
like i was
giving much back the humanitarian work
is completely different i'm dealing with
people
who i've never been involved with before
and
they're very they have they have very
little
so anything i can give them back now
with with the training that i've had
and give them all this real estate back
giving them the homes back
to me that is powerful can you give us
an example of the gratitude that you've
seen
the man who wanted to feed me his best
sheep
he was willing there and then to cut the
sheep as he called it
i presume to barbecue it i stopped him i
urged him please
wait i haven't even i'm just doing here
i'm just here to do a reconnaissance
but he was so pleased that the route
simply from his village
to the water point would be open again
you could see it in his eyes
what does it feel like to be aware that
you there are people who are probably
alive because of the work you've done
i don't openly know that i am saving
lives
but i like to hope that i am um
every ied every mine
every item of uxo that's removed from
this area
is one less hazard for those that live
there so i feel
i'm accomplishing something by every day
i achieve
have you something witnessed a bonus
political role
no but i know
i've lost many friends and
some in the theater that i'm in now
things go wrong you can
you can speculate why
whilst nothing has been witnessed by me
is going wrong i know of
many events that have gone wrong
and you can only do it once
you know one thing you should know about
espionage as well as bomb making
the first mistake is your last mistake
you're not going to live to make another
mistake
and therefore you have to be absolutely
careful you know one
wrong word you know and you are
a head shorter and six feet under